foreign
well Jade I wanted to talk about
something that is about as exciting as
stepping on a Lego brick and that is
taxes but I want to make sure our
audience knows about all the tax changes
maybe some tips and tricks to help them
along the way remind them of some
deadlines yeah all the good stuff let's
do it so let's start with the the big
day to celebrate the holidays aren't
over April 18th is the filing deadline
for all federal tax returns and payments
you can start filing at the end of this
month you'll start getting those W-2s
from your employer if that's your
situation don't put it off guys no and
the good news is you can start getting
some of the paperwork ready now which is
you know make it a date night have fun
with it you're going to start getting
those paperworks in for your investment
statements mortgage interest statements
1099s or whatever have you just kind of
pull all those together put them in a
folder for when it's time that's right
and the extension deadline is October
16th if you are in that bucket there and
so there's some good news about this
year's taxes there are some some bad
news too you yeah so the good the good
news is the standard deduction continues
to climb which is good because that
lowers your taxable income yes that is
correct we like that anything that's
going to make us pay less taxes that is
a good thing you want the bad news now I
no you know what George Let's skip that
I'm just kidding we can't skip it well
the bad news is uh you're gonna get a
smaller refund this year across the
board because there was no economic
impact so you remember all the expanded
tax credits like it was like and you
have a kids here's five thousand dollars
and you have a kid bro they went off
like the amount of money that was coming
through I was like what we have two kids
I was like what is happening this is
different it was wild time so all of
that is gone the expanded tax credits
and deductions are reverting back to
their pre-covered 19 amounts the
charitable charitable contributions
deduction that is out and so uh if most
people are gonna file with the standard
deduction yes so only do itemized if you
can get more than you would have with
the standards yeah and you need to
really sit down with a professional to
really see how that works especially get
a business a small business you
definitely want to get into that with a
you know because you got the personal
side in your business side so yes so if
you're wondering all right I may not get
a refund I might owe how do I save some
money this tax season well the two magic
words are deductions and credits hit me
and these two can get Squishy in
people's brains so here's an easy way to
think about it deductions help lower the
amount of your income that can be taxed
so that's kind of before that's right
after the tax credit so think about you
get your final bill at the restaurant
this is going to it's like actually give
you credits off of that final bill
amount and so think about things like
Earned Income Tax Credit child tax
credit you've heard that Child
Independent Care Credit education credit
so you need to be aware of all the
credits and deductions you might qualify
for yep yep and again working with a tax
professional they'll help you know that
I mean you don't have to know everything
but it's good to go in there with an
idea to just kind of make sure
everything's on the up and up you know
what I'm saying yes and to add to your
homework here there are something called
above the line deductions which are
really helpful so there's things you can
still do even though we're in 2023 to
lower your taxable great idea yeah talk
about that that's great so one of them
that is great is the HSA if you have a
high deductible health plan with an HSA
and you contributed to that HSA you can
deduct that that's sexual income so it's
not too late to do that it's not another
one is IRAs if you fund your traditional
IRA you can do that through you know
April 18th and I think a lot of people
forget that I think people think that
it's over in January because like the
year is restarting but you've got until
you've gotten until tax day April 18th
keep funding and I like to I'm a nerd I
like to get my taxes done as early as
possible but here's why I want to know
if I'm going to owe if I'm gonna have a
refund because you don't owe that money
until April 18th that's true well let's
talk about that a little bit because I
know a lot of people are like oh I'm
gonna get my tax refund I'm gonna do my
taxes I want to do my taxes early so I
can get my thousands and thousands of
dollar check so I can I don't know go do
something that you're probably gonna
spend it all it's like they think Uncle
Sam is Uncle Santa and he's just gifting
you money because you've been such a
good boy it's a horrible it's just
horrible the amount of money that people
lend the government with no interest
zero percent man I wish man that drives
me crazy so here's the deal if you get a
refund it it is not a blessing yes it's
better than like owing ten thousand
dollars but you are just lending that
money to the government interest free
when you do that so you want to get as
close to zero as possible believe it or
not you don't you don't want to owe much
and you don't want to get a big refund
and there's something mentally about
that right when you when you set up your
withholdings to where it's correct right
or you're not yeah you get the perfect
amount you get the perfect amount but
then that money is is cash flow within
your normal monthly you know flow and
you're more likely to do something smart
with that money it's going to be worked
into your budget when you have a refund
towards debt it's going to something fun
I know y'all
you're getting you're getting jet skis
you're out here buying I don't know a
Peloton y'all are out here really buying
things with these with these returns
you're going on vacation unless you're a
Disney stepper if you're a baby stepper
you're like sweet that's going towards
my dad that's true that is true I just
think it's harder to that way it is I
think it's like we're all children deep
down I need to know do you happen to
know the average I don't know if there's
a number for like the average return I
was talking to a friend it's like three
grand exercise in my head I was talking
to a friend he was I said what like what
type of return like what type of tax
return do you get he said his was eight
thousand dollars
wow eight that is that normal somebody
needs to come into my DMs at Jade
warshaw and tell me is that normal that
can't be right so here's here's another
thing to think about if you're trying to
pay off debt and you're like well
inflation and there's so much happening
in the economy I don't have the margin
to pay off debt one thing you can do is
change those withholdings that you keep
getting a big refund every year because
that money will go back into your bank
account instead of sitting with Uncle
Sam all year and that's what we're
talking about we're talking about you
being able to get the maximum amount out
of your paycheck you know sometimes the
way it's set up automatically it's not
in your best interest and you can
actually go back on there claim more
dependents however it is that you do it
to even that out so you're having more
money in your check each month and like
I said before chances are you're going
to be smarter at spending that money yes
and our team has painstakingly created
an amazing Hub as a resource to all of
our listeners out there at
ramseysolutions.com
taxes so we have articles resources
there's an incredible tax prep checklist
that's free I use it every year and I
just go down the line and I start going
yup got that up I gotta go print that I
gotta go save that good job George I
know I told you I'm a nerd I am when you
said that you did it I really imagined
it and I was like yes George does do
this I love it I can see it and the uh
the other thing you can do is if you are
one of those that does it on your own
you use software you've got to check out
Ramsay smart tax this is the no-nonsense
tax software that you can actually trust
there's no hidden fees there's no hidden
agenda we're not here as a gateway drug
to get you into debt products like
TurboTax uh sorry I said it out loud hey
George you know what I told you know
what I told you before the break yes you
have a experience with Intuit which is
the parent company guys he's
I it's hard for me to even get it out of
my mouth well if you're wondering I used
to refer into it if you're wondering why
I have feelings about that we did an
entire episode on my podcast a fine
print about Turbo Tax and how Turbo Tax
is trying to screw you over everything
through their shareholder uh
presentation about how they're going to
make a bajillion dollars from you all
America and it has nothing to do with
taxes it's about how they're going to
use you to create loans and debt and
create money from interest to make
themselves bajillionaires yeah when you
stay broke it's not good no I did into
it as a side Hustle
I'm glad you kept it on the side and now
it's it's gone it's gone oh she gone
well you can check out check out all
those resources including Ramsay smart
tax our awesome tax software just go to
ramsaysolutions.com taxes and like I
said I know this is no one's favorite
thing to think about it's not on your
top 10 list of favorite things it's
number 11 for me I was gonna say I think
George I think this
it feels very productive to get it done
and here's what me and my wife do we
will schedule a a date
right after we finish our taxes we go to
a really nice meal
to treat ourselves because we're
adulting I'm so proud of you let me tell
you something if Sam warshaw said to me
jade the date night is tax night post
tax returns shutting her down I'm
shutting it down right there I'm like
what okay not quite romantic I need to
do a better job of that no George you
you do your Thug but it just it's good
to get it in the rear view mirror get it
done folks if you do tax software go
ahead and start that process the end of
January meet with a tax Pro that's great
schedule that now because it's about to
get crazy for those tax preparers out
there and don't go to those h r blocks
inside the Walmart find a real
professional a dog H R Block but be real